we'll never ever let you down that I can
tell you
speaking in New Hampshire his first time
before supporters since the mass
shootings in Dayton and El Paso Donald
Trump blamed the people he says are
behind us gun violence there is a mental
illness problem that has to be dealt
with it's not the gun that pulls the
trigger it's the person holding the gun
we're going to have to give major
consideration to building new facilities
for those in need we have to do it
absent from Trump's message the
suggestion of universal background
checks something polls show a majority
of US voters support Trump narrowly lost
the state of New Hampshire in the 2016
US election but he's fighting for it in
2020 boasting of creating jobs and
boosting wages claiming any one of the
Democratic candidates running for
president would change that a vote for
any Democrat in 2020 is a vote for the
rise of radical socialism and disruption
the disruption of the American Dream so
whether you love me or hate me they got
a vote for me but democratic protesters
outside Trump's rally
say he hasn't kept his promises in 2016
he pledged to halt opioid overdoses
ravaging the state since taking office
there's been just a modest reduction in
deaths he promised them New Hampshire
specifically is going to take care of
the opioid crisis I'm sorry can you
point to one thing they've done in New
Hampshire Trump boasts of adding 20,000
jobs and dropping the state's
unemployment rate to just two point five
percent supporters say it's those
numbers that will help Trump win
re-election in this politically divided
state the economy is great
unemployment's down lowest it's ever
been and I think the people in New
Hampshire recognize that
but Trump's Democratic rivals are
challenging his record on the economy
and making a big push for votes in New
Hampshire polls show a majority of
Americans are tired of Donald Trump's
rhetoric and constant tweeting yet some
still support him because of a strong US
economy but reports of a looming
recession could spell trouble for Trump
Kimberly Hellcat al Jazeera Manchester
New Hampshire